Saying that most of our ocean floor is unmapped
isn't entirely true. We do have maps created by
satellites that do all this fancy measuring
of differences in gravity caused by the ocean
floor's topography. *explosion sounds* But the
resolution of these maps isn't great. These
satellite maps only show features larger than
five kilometers, which is like huge. Meanwhile,
our maps of friggin’ Mars have a resolution of
like six meters. So what's the benefit of having
a detailed map of our ocean? For starters, it's
just freakin’ cool. But also the ocean is hugely
important to our survival. Aside from providing
me with delicious seafood, it's also the largest
carbon sink that we have on our planet. And it
helps regulate all sorts of different things.
Like, I don't know, global temperatures might be
important. Not to mention we'll probably find new
resources that we can use, which actually
now that I think about it could totally
backfire because humans kind of suck at finding
resources and not totally exploiting them beyond
repair. That being said, how do we even begin to
protect something that we don't even know exists?